저는 제가
웬만해서 제 인스타그램
마파라는 분들은 다 패션
종사자잖아요. 선민님 포함해서.
그래서 와이 브랜드 새로운데 하면은
대부분 누군가가 팔로하고 있어요.
근데 제가이 브랜드는 최근에 좀 어
괜찮은데 하면서 봤는데이 브랜드는
아무도 팔로한 사람이 없었어요.
아
그래?
어 그 쉽지 않은데.
궁금하다.
해외야? 국내야?
해외요?
해외야
해외야? 국내야?
해외요?
해외야
해외야? 국내야?
해외요?
해외야
균는 무조건 해외죠.
아니요.
그렇잖아. 아까 아노멘토
얘기했잖아요.
아비바 지페이슈라고 하세요? 처음
지어낸 거 아니에요? 나 이거 너가
만든 브랜드 아니야?
그냥 얘기한 거
아니야? 에센스에도 있어요.
에센스에도 있고. 근데 이게 보니까
그 중국이랑 일본 그 계열의
디자이너인데 그 활동지는
뉴욕이거든요.
그래가지고 최근에 제가
이거 어떻게 알게 됐냐면 매클레즈에서
다행을 시작을 했어요.
그래가지고
보는데
제가 그 어 메클래즈에서 조금
산 적이 있어서 뭐 그 카톡도 오거든
입구 되면
조금 산다고 해는게 아닌
조금 사진
않았나 본데. 근데 아무튼 근데
봤는데 어 너무 예쁜 거예요.
근데 제가 가장 좀 인상
깊었던게이 요게이
룩이 되게 전하거든요. 왜냐하면은
밝기 좀 올리면
뭐 아우터가 이너가
바지 아 저는
이거 바지야. 두
가지인데이
보면은 이너를 되게 롱하게 빼고
그다음에 위에다가 숏탄 자켓 입고
그다음에 저 이게 스카프의 넥타이처럼
이렇게 둘러서 뺐잖아요.
이게 너무
제가
한번쯤 시도해 보고 싶은
이것보다 조금 기장이 짧아 되잖아.
저는 왜냐하면 저의 빛나간 추측일 수
있지만 언젠가는 이런 롱한 기장의
원피스 같은 느낌에
것이 남자도 많이 입을 것 같아.
음.
왜냐면 저는 그거 언제 느꼈냐면
르메르 행사 때 홍태준 씨가
그여
르메르 여자 드라이실 그 드레스를
원피스를 샀어요.
진짜 잘 어울리고
진짜 멋있는
느낌이 드는데 어쨌든
이런 느낌의 전 스카프 연출도 되게
좋고 그다음에 얘네도 소재를 쓰는 게
아 근데 아 그 봐봐 그냥 원피스야.
뭐야 이거 전포스트야? 아니 아니
이거 단추가 있는 걸 보니까
여기까지가 하프로 떨어지는 원피스
같은 거 같아. 제 생각에 이거
자체가 여자룩인 거 같아요.
그래서 어찌됐던 아비바 디페이슈
디페이슈 스펠링 봐봐.
아비바
디페이슈
아
6 베이스드 아비바
디페이슈
아
6 베이스드 아비바
디페이슈
아
6 베이스드 아비바
디페이슈
아 근데 진짜 그 중국
느낌이네. 그니까 그 이름이
야
이거는 거의 그냥 일부러 찾아오면 좀
진짜 제가 너무 예쁘다 생각했어요.
인스타도 보면은 더 좋긴 한데 이런
룩이 보면은
좀 애매한 색깔에 대해
많이 쓰고
그다음에 전 이런
칼라 없는 느낌이나 로망카라 쓰는 거
되게 좋아하거든요.
음.
그리고
아
되게 좋아하거든요.
음.
그리고
아
되게 좋아하거든요.
음.
그리고
아
근데 요즘에 내가 느끼는 건데
밴드카라 되게 유행할 것 같아요.
그죠? 그죠? 음. 예전에 했던 거
어 그러니까 굳이 따지면 헬리넥이라
말이 좀 그렇고 밴드 컬러의
아우터들이 되게
더 보이지 않을까
이런 생각 들었어. 이거 선 지상
선명이 살짝 좋을 것 같은데 거 아
이거 벨벳인가? 여기가
내가 내가 나도 이렇다고 해서 다
좋아하지 않아.
예. 아무튼 저의 추구미 중 하나가이
위 시리즈 추구미 중 하나가이
룩이라서
음
그래서 전 아직이
룩이라서
음
그래서 전 아직이
룩이라서
음
그래서 전 아직이
브랜드는 더 알아보긴 해야 되지만 음
그래도
좋아하게 될 것 같은
브랜드다. 예. 한은 얘기를 하고
싶었어.
음.
아, 생각나신 거
싶었어.
음.
아, 생각나신 거
싶었어.
음.
아, 생각나신 거
있으면
어, 나도 있어. 나 갑자기
여기다 브랜드를 보니까 생각이 나.
예. 아, 내가 요즘에 그냥
그 보다 보니까 어, 소셔 줄게.
어, 저 이거 얘기하려는데.
아,
그래?
그데 뺏은 거야?
아니요. 저도 저도
이거 다음에 얘기하려서요. 이거 되게
예쁘지 않아요?
아,이 소셜
치키라는이 브랜드를 알게 된지는 얼마
안 됐는데. 전 완전 최면이에요.
나는 그 아까 그 민규가 보여준 그
브랜드의 룩을 보니까 이게 너무
생각이 나는 거
딱 그 맞아요.
어
생각이 나는 거
딱 그 맞아요.
어
생각이 나는 거
딱 그 맞아요.
어
나는 90 8 90년대 그 일본에서
하는 그 더블 수트 이런 거 있잖아.
우리가 옛날에 뭐
그러네요.
그 옛날
우리가 옛날에 뭐
그러네요.
그 옛날
우리가 옛날에 뭐
그러네요.
그 옛날
향의
그런 시리즈물들이나 영화들을
보면 이런 일본 느낌의 그런 수트들이
그 독특한 형태가 있단 말이야.
근데
그런 느낌이 난 되게 새롭더라고. 이
이런 걸 좋아하기도 했지만 이제
이렇게
루프 자체를 근데 약간 그런
느낌으로 찍는 거 하나만 눌러봐
주시면 안 돼요.
음.
이런 뭔가
주시면 안 돼요.
음.
이런 뭔가
주시면 안 돼요.
음.
이런 뭔가
오버실루엣의 더블에다가 이런 형태가
뭔가
되게 그 옛날 느낌 나면서도 또
요즘스럽기도 하고 오히려 모던하기도
하고
그리고 앞으로 이렇게 입는
사람들로 늘어날까 뭐 이런 생각도 좀
들더라고.
이것도 이것도
어 이런
들더라고.
이것도 이것도
어 이런
들더라고.
이것도 이것도
어 이런
거.
그러니까 저는 이런 테일러링 베이스의
브랜드 컬렉션 중에 제일 먼저
생각나는 건 그 생로랑 이사f 그
이거 에디스 에디래 그 입생로랑
스타일로 다 이렇게 잠자리 한경 쓰고
근데
그거랑은 또 완전 다르잖아.
완전
다르잖아요. 다 이거는 조금
얘네가 얘기하는게 제패니스
트레디션스라고 하잖아.
그래서 오히려
이런 그 이렇게 오버하게 입었었던
그런 그 수트의 형태를 자기네 대한
트래디션이라 생각하고 있는 거 같아.
아
그래서 그 오려 부각시켜가지고 좀
내보낸 느낌이 있더라고.
이런이 이런
연출부터가
아 근데 쉽지 않은데
접근하기가 난다요.
일본의 연미복은
되게 우리나라랑 미국이랑 되게 다른
느낌이거든. 그런
그런 거기에서
영감을 받은 그런 컬렉션이 아닌가 나
이런 생각이 들어서 어이 브랜드 난
되게
되게 재밌다고 생각해. 근데
이게 당연히 셀러브라고 생각은 저기
안 하고 그죠.
근데 좋은 브랜드다.
근데 모르겠어. 나는 이런 거는 아까
홍태준 얘기했지만 되게 모델들이
입어야지 되게 이쁠 것 같은 생각도
되게 많이 했어. 어떤 느낌인지
알지? 그죠? 이런 오버한 실렛이
어울리려면은 기럭
어느 기럭지로 딱
그 빼는게 있어야 되거든. 근데
그런게 좀 아쉽지.
내가 입긴 쉽지
않을거.
이런 와이드한 바지는 사실
일반인들이 입으면 너무 짧아보.
이것도 멋있다 생겼어요. 이게
코주로인가?
그지?
근데 이거 완전
코주로인가?
그지?
근데 이거 완전
코주로인가?
그지?
근데 이거 완전
그 기 색깔.
그지? 그지?
근데 약간 저 정도의 통은 그냥
있잖아.
그죠?
네. 저 정도.
있잖아.
그죠?
네. 저 정도.
있잖아.
그죠?
네. 저 정도.
그리고 아까이 전룩이랑 전전룩이랑
공통점이 안에 인어나 스카프 같은 걸
되게 화려한 색깔 넣잖아요. 근데
이게 여성 여성룩에서 되게 많이
나오는 그런 그
뭐가 코디 방법인데
이런게 좀 최근에 더 끌리더라고요.
왜냐면 그냥 셔츠 단품만 봤을 때
화려한 거 잘 안 사잖아요.
그지?
그지? 근데 인어로 넣으면은 되게
예쁘다 그런 생각이 들어서 그런 것도
좀 참고하게 좋은 브랜드 같다
생각했어요.
이런 건 되게 바지는
오버하게 뺐는데 자켓 실루에서 되게
또 쓰 버튼이고
어 슬림마하게 가져간
것도 있고
와 근데
완전 쉽지 않다. 커머셜한 브랜드.
어 이것도 진짜
어 진짜 커머셜하지
않아. 내가 느끼는 거는 색깔도 아까
민규 했던 것처럼 색깔도 되게
요즘스러운 색깔이 아니야. 와 이거
거 방금 거 방금 거 진짜 옛날
우리
어머니 세대 머리스타일는데 약간
그
이거 립스틱 색깔도 그렇고
와
오렌지족 이런 느낌이어 잘 찍었다.
그지?
근데 약간 사진 색감도 일부러
이렇게 뺀 거 같은데
그렇게 뺀 거
같아. 그니까 그런 느낌을 주는 거
같아.
그래. 어이 아까 것도 괜찮은 거
같아. 그 여자 여자분 그 여자분
이렇게 시작하면 나는 도대체 무슨
브랜드일 거니?
이렇게 코트
이건
브랜드일 거니?
이렇게 코트
이건
브랜드일 거니?
이렇게 코트
이건
사실 위시리스트는 아니지.
근데이이 브랜드를 경험해 보고
싶어요. 수시오스키랑 아비바 지페이
지페이슈
예
제가 요새 약간 나이가
지페이슈
예
제가 요새 약간 나이가
지페이슈
예
제가 요새 약간 나이가
들었나라고 생각이 드는게 저는 셔트랑
자켓검도 잘 안 입어요.
음
그게 한
자켓검도 잘 안 입어요.
음
그게 한
자켓검도 잘 안 입어요.
음
그게 한
한 1, 2년 한 2, 3년 입사
초기만 해도 되게 저 셔츠랑 자켓
되게 자주 입었었는데 최근에는 약간
셔츠 재켓을 거의 안 입는 거 같고
저는 요새 러닝 브랜드를 많이 보니까
어 이거 최근에 생긴데 아니야? 어
석유의 매당인 체원이 생겼어요. 예
그래가지고 지난번에 디스트릭트 비전
그 러닝 했을 때
디렉터가 와가지고
근데 이게 뭔가 되게 체복 같은데
입으니까
괜찮았어.
어 되게 웨어업을
입으니까
괜찮았어.
어 되게 웨어업을
입으니까
괜찮았어.
어 되게 웨어업을
해 보이고 그냥 저 뭔가 휘뚜루마두루
일상복에도 잘 입을 것 같고
뭐
운동할 때도 입을 수 있을 것 같고
해가지고
소재가 괜찮았어요. 나일론
소재였는데 뭔가 통기성도 좋은 거
같고
음
그리고 막 엄청 드러나지
같고
음
그리고 막 엄청 드러나지
같고
음
그리고 막 엄청 드러나지
않는듯한 그런 느낌이 좋았어.이 이
브랜드가 뭔가
뭐 로고가 달려 있긴
한데
응.
아 근데 나는이 브랜드
한데
응.
아 근데 나는이 브랜드
한데
응.
아 근데 나는이 브랜드
로고도 되게 좋다 생각해.
이게왜
디스트릭트 미션이야?
응.
음
로고가 두 타입 두 가지 타입인
거 같아.
아까 너 그 옷에 박혀
있던 그런도 있고 맞아.
그런 것도
있고이 눈알 모양으로 된 로고도
있고.
근데 여기가 원래 내가
알기로는 그 선글라스 위주로 처음에
많이 했었던 걸 알고.
최근에
콜라보도 나왔잖아요. 그 파프랑
이게
아마 처음에 아이웨어 베이스로
시작했을 거. 그 아마 아마 비전이
달려 있는 걸 알고 있 그래서 비전이
거기서 이제 조금 발전해 가지고 이제
의료도 나오는 걸로 알고 있고
정확한
정부지 모르겠습니다.
그래서 저는
사실 제가 좀 피부톤이 어두워서
카키랑 브라운이 안 어울리는데
약간
이게 옥인지는 잘 모르겠는데 항상
예쁘다 싶은 옷은 브라운과 카입니다.
그래서 얘를 좀 사보고 싶은 좀
욕심이 있습니다. 입어
보셨어요?
아니 못 입어 봤어. 가격이 세다.
어
근데 기본적으로 러닝 브랜드들이
가격대가 좀 높더라고. 이게 기능성
소재여서 그런지 잘 모르겠는데
룰루레
디테일한번 룰루레모는 좀 가격이
그래도 괜찮았잖아요.
근데 뭔가 이런
나일론하고 약간 좀 빠스락 걸리는
나일론 같은 느낌이거든요.
그래가지고
어 되게 잘 입을 거 같다.
소재감이
좋더라고요. 만져 봤을 때.
어 이거
그거네. 월메틱스네.
명
올매틱스라고 그 이태리에서 유명한
그 화섬으로 유명한 그런
텍스타일
브랜드거든.
그래서 올매틱스라고
하면은 되게 비싼 소재로는 알고
있어. 그래서 올매스 소재를 쓴 옷은
나도 되게 좋다고 느낀다.
어 그
전이 로고가 뭔가 예뻐요.
어이 로고
진짜
어 뭔가 약간
이거이 로그 되게
진짜
어 뭔가 약간
이거이 로그 되게
진짜
어 뭔가 약간
이거이 로그 되게
예쁘다.
응
그리고 엄청 직관적이고
예쁘다.
응
그리고 엄청 직관적이고
예쁘다.
응
그리고 엄청 직관적이고
그러게
그래서 디렉터가이 자켓을 입고
있는데 사실이 자켓이 예쁘다고 생각을
못 하고 있었거든요.
근데 그 친구가
입고 뛰는데 되게 어
되게 좋다
예쁘다 이런 느낌이더고요.
그래서
저는 약간 이제
저의 위시리스트에
당겨 있는 것 중에 하나입니다. 음.
근데 러닝 브랜드들이 다 싸진
않더라.
그지?
가격대가 다
요즘 다
않더라.
그지?
가격대가 다
요즘 다
않더라.
그지?
가격대가 다
요즘 다
막 야 한국들 좋아해. 올려 올려.
근데 그런 건데 세티스파이가 뭐 요새
최근에 시작한 브랜드가 아니잖아.
오래됐지.
그래서 예전에는 다 막
할인 들어갔을 때 살 수 있고 막
이랬었는데 요새 워낙 봄이다 보니까
요즘 편기잖아.
예. 요새는 뭐
정석가로도 사기 힘드니까. 아니 그
탱크루스 코모의 초반에 나왔을
때만해도 그게 한 1년에서 1년 반
전인가 그때는 다 시즌오프 거의 다
넘어왔었어. 맞아.
아 그래.
예.
넘어왔었어. 맞아.
아 그래.
예.
넘어왔었어. 맞아.
아 그래.
예.
그래서 아 이거 뭐 뭐 어떻네 맞네
뭐 이런 생각이 안 들었었는데 근데
최근에 지금 보시면 뭐
여기 다
싹다품이잖아.
무슨
응. 비싸다는
싹다품이잖아.
무슨
응. 비싸다는
싹다품이잖아.
무슨
응. 비싸다는
느낌이 없잖아. 한데
비싸요.
막 그렇게 가격대가 접근성
있는 가격대는 아닌 거 같아요.
근데
얘네가 소재 개발도 다 하고 그다음에
원래 있던 MD한테들은 걸로는 이
빈티지스러운 그 느낌을 주기 위해서
이렇게 빵꾸를 뚫었잖아요. 근데
그것도 그 사람의 땀구멍 배치 그거를
보고 되게 인체공학적으로 뚫었다고 전
알고 있어요.
뭔가 나도 그 얘기
들었던 거 같아.
어
그래서 뭐
들었던 거 같아.
어
그래서 뭐
들었던 거 같아.
어
그래서 뭐
믿거나 알거나 배치
아니 근데 그분이
뭐 맞는 말이지 않을까? 왜냐면
그분이 실제로 그 본국 사람 안 나
아니 근데 실제로 이거 지금 다 제가
입고 있습니다 지금
아니 그 뚫린게
다 똑같네
이거 좀 커진 거 같은데
선면이
여기 만나는 친구들마다 다 후배 파악
조금 넓어지는 이슈가 있는데
아 근데
민규말이 맞는 거 같은게 다 똑같아
그
구멍 배치들이
이거 그러면
그
구멍 배치들이
이거 그러면
그
구멍 배치들이
이거 그러면
수작업으로 뚫는게 아니네요.
그럼
이렇게 패턴에 패턴에 따 놨겠죠?
그래서 펀칭하는 건가?
내가 느끼기는
펀칭 계기로 하는게 아닐까? 팡
뭐 나 본 적은 없지만
일단 혹시
이분을
아시니까 딜커니
어
유명하시잖아
아
아시니까 딜커니
어
유명하시잖아
아
아시니까 딜커니
어
유명하시잖아
아
사진 착가 아닌가
예 지금은
돌아가셨는데
응
제가 그 프렌치 워크
돌아가셨는데
응
제가 그 프렌치 워크
돌아가셨는데
응
제가 그 프렌치 워크
자켓을 되게 꽂혔어요.
아이 사람
그걸로 유명하잖아.
근데 이분은
어디였더라? 빠리에 있는 빈티지
샵에서 20유론 가지고 샀대요
이거는.
음
완전 진짜 그런 빈티지인
이거는.
음
완전 진짜 그런 빈티지인
이거는.
음
완전 진짜 그런 빈티지인
거죠. 근데 이분이 이분이 프렌치
워크
자켓에이 쨍한 파란색이 너무 예쁜
거예요. 그리고 저도 앞자리가 최근에
바뀌어서
좀 쨍한 색깔의 그런
그
바뀌어서
좀 쨍한 색깔의 그런
그
바뀌어서
좀 쨍한 색깔의 그런
그
의류가 막 당기더라고요.
근데 진짜
쨍하다.
예. 전 이런 쨍함이 너무
좋아요. 그 사실 이거 말게 뭐야?
저는 그 르몽색 미쉘
아 르몽색 미쉘
제일 뭐 그러니까 엄청 많이
찾아봤거든요. 저도 렌치워크 자켓
여기서 나온 그
모이스킨 모이스킨이 근데 몰스킨이
원래 근본 아니에요?
맞아요.
프렌치는
근데이 브랜드가 프렌치
자켓으로론 워크 자켓으로론 되게 많이
얘랑 벨 벨트라 얘랑 벨트라가 두
탈인데
여기 걸 사지 않을까?
음
그지?이
여기 걸 사지 않을까?
음
그지?이
여기 걸 사지 않을까?
음
그지?이
한국에 들어오지 않았어? 한국에
있어요. 들어장도 있을걸.
SSF에도
있고 한남동에 플레드 집이 있어요.
맞아.
요거.
음.
사실 이거에 좀
맞아.
요거.
음.
사실 이거에 좀
맞아.
요거.
음.
사실 이거에 좀
펌프가 어떤 거는 빌커닝하면은 좀
찾아보다 가게 된 거고.
음. 해리스타일스.
헤리스타일스가 최근에 이걸 입었어요.
음.
근데 이거 더러울 거예요.
아,
음.
근데 이거 더러울 거예요.
아,
음.
근데 이거 더러울 거예요.
아,
그래.
그래가지고 무슨 프렌치 워크다했어요,
내가.
돈에 물처럼 쓸 수 있는 사람도
아니고 더로우에서 내가 사야 되나?
더로우 프렌스 자켓 얼마야? 300한
거
찾아보지도 않았어요. 한번
볼까요? 아니야. 괜찮아.
근데
이거는 꼭 더로에 살 필요는 없잖아.
혹시 드신 거 같은데.
왜요?
1650달러인데 품절이에요.
아
비싸다.데
비싼 이유는 있겠지.
네. 그
더러우니까
더러우니까도 그지.
더럽네.
근데 얘는 좀 많이 그 의역이
됐잖아요. 이런 포켓의 위치나
기장이나 품이나 근데 전 이런 걸
얘
프렌치 치고 좀 긴 거 같은데
맞아요. 얘
얘랑 비교를 해 봐도
응
맞아요. 얘
얘랑 비교를 해 봐도
응
맞아요. 얘
얘랑 비교를 해 봐도
응
얘도 이렇게 얘가이 친구가 입은 거랑
이렇게
길 확실히 길
이분이 입으신
이렇게
길 확실히 길
이분이 입으신
이렇게
길 확실히 길
이분이 입으신
거랑 확실히 다르잖아 근데
이게
예쁜데
아까 그거는 계속 입어서 빈트지하면
살려야 될 거 같아
예 얘는 맞아
완전 죽여놔야 돼요.
그니까
네
근데
완전 죽여놔야 돼요.
그니까
네
근데
완전 죽여놔야 돼요.
그니까
네
근데
뭐 나쁘지 않은 거 같아. 그래서
한번 이번에 사기 전에
한번 한나
한번가 볼까 생각 중이에요.
입어
봐야 될 것 같아요. 사이즈 감도 잘
모르겠고.
나 이제 국내 브랜드로 좀
넘어가
볼게. 아니 내가
그 미키마우스
귀엽던데.
어 미키 어 미키마. 어
이거 귀엽다.
이게 지금 어제
솔다운이긴 한데
이런
미키마우스를 이제 모티브로
어 저 링
티셔츠 좋아하는데
어 개발한 티셔츠가
난 되게 이쁘더라고.
요즘에는 어떻게
보면 이런 빈티스러운 그래픽이
유행이잖아. 믹.
어 밍이란 작가와의
콜라 콜라보레이션이라고 하더라고.
그리고
그 내가 이제 전에 나왔던 거
사고 싶었던 건 이런
케이트모스가 들어가는 거거든.
케이트모스.
예쁘다.
뭔가 옛날
케이트모스.
예쁘다.
뭔가 옛날
케이트모스.
예쁘다.
뭔가 옛날
슈프림 같은 느낌.
어 맞아.
케이트무스 하면 또
슈프림이잖아. 이제
이거 이거 되게
사고 싶더라고. 나도. 어쨌든 나는
이제 이런 그 뭔가 고증에 그냥
그래픽하 되나? 이런 것들이 되게
좋아보. 그럼 오늘 입으신 것도
슈프림 약간 그 고등 있는
고등 있는
백설 공
요즘에 이런 또 유행이잖아.
고지
이게 내가 요즘 발견한데 폭대
너드샵이었나?
응 이름이 폭데 너드샵이라고 있거든.
아이 뭐라 설명해야 되지? 요즘스러운
그래픽 그
약간 초기 확킹 어섬
그다음에 그 리펜디
어 맞아 맞아.
근데 이제 그런 것들 그니까
뭔가
되게 아마추어한 그래픽을 써서 오히려
더 힙하게 만드는 것들 있잖아.
로하네요.
어. 되게 로한 그래픽도
있잖아. 근데 이제 내가 사고 싶었던
거는 이거 되게 사고 싶더라고.이
브랜드 요즘 보고 있었어.이
브랜드인지 샵인지 정확히 모르겠어.
근데 이제
이런 느낌에 빨간색 후드를
좀 사고 싶다는 생각 되게 많이
했었거든.
아
되게 버이 딱 적혀
했었거든.
아
되게 버이 딱 적혀
했었거든.
아
되게 버이 딱 적혀
있네.
너드
너드게 예쁘다.
어 나 개쌉 너드니까
그냥 너드라고 보여 줘야 되겠다 싶은
생각도 들고 아무튼이 샵을 되게
가보고 싶다는 생각 되게 했었어.
이거 우리나라 거예요.
우리나라. 어
근데 보니까 일본에서도 퍼하고 뭐
확인하더라고.
그래요? 인기가 좀
있나 보다.
인기가 좀 있나 봐.
그래서 뭐 되게 되게 재밌는 그래픽이
많더라고. 이런 브랜드들의 아이템들이
좀 사고 싶다는 생각이 요즘 많이
했었어.
음스럽기도 하고
그거에 집착하는 순간
MG인이 된 거
같은데. 아니 그냥 좋아서
아까
말했듯이 타이가 사실 굉장히
좋아하는데
음
아 저이 얘네이
좋아하는데
음
아 저이 얘네이
좋아하는데
음
아 저이 얘네이
변태스러움이 좋아요. 일단은 이렇게
롯 해 가지고
원부터 막쓰 4파 해서
음
돼 있는 거이
사람이
엄청 컬렉션
음
돼 있는 거이
사람이
엄청 컬렉션
음
돼 있는 거이
사람이
엄청 컬렉션
컬렉팅을 많이 해서 자기가
고고학자처럼 역사학자처럼 이렇게
공부를 많이 했는데
각 개별 시리즈를
정리하는 하듯이 이런 식으로 정리를
해 놓은 거예요. 본인의 컬렉션도.
음.
근데 여기서 전 악셀을 좀 사고
싶은 게
음
저는 막 사람들이 뭘
싶은 게
음
저는 막 사람들이 뭘
싶은 게
음
저는 막 사람들이 뭘
보면은 막
어떤 옷이 사고 싶어지냐
하는데 전 그런게 대중이 없는데
최근에
김나영 씨 유튜브에
음
최근에
김나영 씨 유튜브에
음
최근에
김나영 씨 유튜브에
음
에디터분이 출연을 하셨어요.
그래서
약간 여기 앞에이 벨트가
음
좀 아 다르긴 한 거 같은데 이런
브라운 벨트를
치노 팬츠에다
매칭하는게 되게 예쁜 거예요. 근데이
찡이 좀 예쁜 거 같아서. 물론 저
브라운 베트가 있긴 한데.
어,
여기
브라운 베트가 있긴 한데.
어,
여기
브라운 베트가 있긴 한데.
어,
여기
보면은 요거. 어, 비슷한 거
같은데.
예, 그렇죠.
아, 근데
같은데.
예, 그렇죠.
아, 근데
같은데.
예, 그렇죠.
아, 근데
이거 되게 이쁘다.
괜찮죠?
어.
이거 되게 이쁘다.
괜찮죠?
어.
이거 되게 이쁘다.
괜찮죠?
어.
아, 버클이 너무 이쁜데.
예,
그렇죠. 그래서 지금 제 친구 일본가
있는데
어, 부탁했어.
예.
있는데
어, 부탁했어.
예.
있는데
어, 부탁했어.
예.
부탁했나?
이거 얼마야?
24만 원.
부탁했나?
이거 얼마야?
24만 원.
부탁했나?
이거 얼마야?
24만 원.
아, 그렇게
근데 한국 넘으면 30만
원 그냥 넘어가는
아, 얘 벨트 색감
너무 이쁘다.
이거 괜찮아. 얘 이게
음. 저는 타이가를 그래도 한 이제
한 3, 4년 좋아했는데 이게
시즌
초반부터
음
아 그냥 캐리오
캐리오
초반부터
음
아 그냥 캐리오
캐리오
초반부터
음
아 그냥 캐리오
캐리오
캐리 버클이 너무 이쁘다 근데 이거
내던 거
너입해서 했을 때 되게
이쁜데
그죠
이것도
여기서 아
이쁜데
그죠
이것도
여기서 아
이쁜데
그죠
이것도
여기서 아
아마미섬 아마미 오시마 여기서 얘도
이렇게 머드다잉을 하거든요.
아
여기가 그 비즈비 하는데
아무튼 뭐
이건
머드나잉 아마미 오시마 배웠다.
근데 이게 아마미오섬인가 뭐 이렇게
부를 거예요. 우리나라말로. 요거랑
뭐 저희 가방 치고.
음.
이건 좀
뭐 저희 가방 치고.
음.
이건 좀
뭐 저희 가방 치고.
음.
이건 좀
도전적인데.
서스펜더.
지금 이걸
도전적인데.
서스펜더.
지금 이걸
도전적인데.
서스펜더.
지금 이걸
사게.
아. 아. 이거 이거 좀 잘
입어야 되는데.
네.
아, 그때 제가
입어야 되는데.
네.
아, 그때 제가
입어야 되는데.
네.
아, 그때 제가
올해 2월 달에 교투 갔을 때
있었거든요.
응.
그때 안 샀어요.
있었거든요.
응.
그때 안 샀어요.
있었거든요.
응.
그때 안 샀어요.
음.
근데 아, 계속 아름 거리는
거.
근데 너 잘 어울릴 거 같은데.
예. 저 그냥 약간 얘거 뒤로도 한번
써 보고 싶고 앞으로도 한번 써 보고
싶고.
근데 빡세긴 하지.
예.
싶고.
근데 빡세긴 하지.
예.
싶고.
근데 빡세긴 하지.
예.
빡세다.
진짜 그럼 서스펜더까지 해야
될 거 같은 느낌이긴 한데
이런 거 하고 와킹 같은 거 해야
되겠다. 뭔지 알지?
그 이거 쓰고
와킹 춤 추 사람도 많단 말이야.
저희 팀에 춤을 되게 잘 치는 후배
친구 하나 있는데 그 친구가 최근에
이런 뉴스보이 캡을 썼는데 어 근데
뭔가
괜찮더라고요.
그것 때문이었나?
메은 타가에서 어떤 거? 나는
타이가에서 민교랑 그
타이가 아 펜스댄스 가서 거기서 제가
타이가를 입문을 했거든요.
아직
있구나. 알겠네.
근데 이게 펜스
댄스 에디션이 있더라고. 근데 뭐
아까도 말씀드렸던 것처럼 제가 이런
느낌이 이런 색감을 좋아하거든요.
그래가지고 이거는 사실 뭐 한번 가서
입어보고 싶다.
음.
왜냐면 입어
입어보고 싶다.
음.
왜냐면 입어
입어보고 싶다.
음.
왜냐면 입어
봐야지 색감을 알 수 있을 것 같다.
근데 뭔가 이런
워싱감이라든지 제가 이런이 뭐라
되냐? 이런 그냥
맞아.
코벌 재켓, 트러커 느낌의 재켓 이런
걸 되게 좋아해요. 그래가지고
한번
입어 가서 입어봐야지. 입어 봐야지
하고 있는 거고.
아, 근데 가격이
싸지 않다.
엄청 비싸요. 맞아요.
특히 이게 일본 브랜드들이 특히 그런
거 같은데 한국 넘으면 가격이 뛰는
정도가 좀 큰 거 같은
그지?
예쁘더라고.
근데 이게 그때 들었을
때이 제품이었나? 이게 감으로 감이랑
철로 다잉을 했었나?
음.
감. 먹는
철로 다잉을 했었나?
음.
감. 먹는
철로 다잉을 했었나?
음.
감. 먹는
감.
먹는. 먹는 감이랑 이런 걸로
그 했던 걸로 설명을 들었었어요.
할
수밖에 없네.
그러니까
먹는 걸로
수밖에 없네.
그러니까
먹는 걸로
수밖에 없네.
그러니까
먹는 걸로
장하시
뭐 이런 걸
먹는 걸로
장하시
뭐 이런 걸
먹는 걸로
장하시
뭐 이런 걸
먹는 걸로
장치니까 비싼 거지.
저 얘도
예쁜데.
어 얘도 예뻐.
어
나 둘
예쁜데.
어 얘도 예뻐.
어
나 둘
예쁜데.
어 얘도 예뻐.
어
나 둘
다 가서 입어보고 싶어.
얘 한번
가보.
아 근데 이것만 입어보러
가게.
근데 저희 둘이 가면은 제
장담하는데 누가 하나 잡아 줘야
돼요. 그 200만 원씩 쓰고이
색감이 예쁘더라고. 뭐
이거 괜 이거
이게 너무 마음에 든다. 옛날 같아서
마음에 안 들었는데. 근데 얘네가
사이즈가 그렇게 막 어떤지 모르겠어
가지고 함부로 결정부터 못 하겠어.
음.
그래서 한번 가서 이어보고
싶다.
내 둘이 타이가 되게
좋아하네.
제가 전파를 했어요.
민규가 좋아하고 저는
너 이거 타이가
타이가
전 새로운 브랜드 입어 보는
거 좋아해 가지고
그지?
얇죠.이가이
거 좋아해 가지고
그지?
얇죠.이가이
거 좋아해 가지고
그지?
얇죠.이가이
가방이 되게 근데 요새 많이 사던데
이게. 그리고 봉태균 님이 그 레더를
드셨어요. 그래가지고 지금 보면은
얘도 솔다웃
솔다웃
뉴스보이 백 뭐야? 뉴스보이
밴
얘가 독특한게 여기가 되게
넓어요. 어깨 스트랩이 그래서 그만에
좀 매력이 있는
이거는 딱 어깨로만
매는 한쪽 어깨로만 매는 거네.
크로스가 안 돼요.
크로스가 안 되.
여자 크로스
여자분들은 할 수
있어요. 근데 남자분들은 좀 이상해.
옹졸해 보여. 이상이.
그래 얘가 조절이 안 되잖아요.
응.
그지?
조절이 안 돼가지고.
아,
그지?
조절이 안 돼가지고.
아,
그지?
조절이 안 돼가지고.
아,
근데 나 아까 네가 얘기한 벨트 되게
예쁘다.
이거 색감이 되게 예쁘다.
이거 되게 예쁘다.
맥클레즈 있긴
해요.
아니 그 가죽이이 오묘한
느낌이 너무 좋아.
내추럴 아이가 진짜 비싸긴 한 거
같아.
나는 그 다행을 해봤자
해보잖아. 근데 다행하는게 이게 진짜
그게 실력인 거 같아.
아, 그래요?
다행하는 그 공장의 실력
다잉을 하는
거는
잘하려면 비싸야 되는게 맞는 거
같아. 비쌀수록 잘한다. 이게 맞는
거.
그렇게 빼는 게
꽤 어려운
거.
그렇게 빼는 게
꽤 어려운
거.
그렇게 빼는 게
꽤 어려운
작업인가요?
난 어려운 작업이라고
생각이 들어. 퀄리티를 못 맞추는데도
너무 많아 가지고. 아, 그 개체별
차이가 너무 많이 벌 벌어질 것
같은데.
그지? 개체별 차이도 커서
뭐 중간중간 사고가 되게 많이 난단
말이야. 그래요.
요즘엔 특히나
다행기법을 한 옷들이 많잖아.
근데
그럴수록 진짜 퀄리티를 맞추는게 더
힘들다 생각을 많이 하거든. 그래서
이제 그런 거를 더
이제 실력이
판가는 난다. 잘한데 안 못한 데가.
음. 제가 그러면 해도 되나요?
그렇지.
저 자산물 한번 가겠습니다.
어 자사울이라면
자산물이라 좀 웃기다. 근데
딱 여기서 외친 거 같아.
혹시나
인나해서
저는
코머리
아 코머리
코머리도
어
한두
코머리
아 코머리
코머리도
어
한두
코머리
아 코머리
코머리도
어
한두
개씩 한두 개씩 사고 있긴 한데
코머리 멋있죠.
전 요새 좀이 입기 편한 옷을 계속
추구하다 보니까
뭔가 이게 눈에
들어오더라고요. 어 사사이 나왔네.
사사이즈 하나
점은 되게 뭐 하나
꽂치면 예의 주시 하나 보네요.
사사이즈 그거 한 개 살아 있는 거
봤었는데 나갔네.
근데 재질이
독특한데요. 약간 테리 소재 아
근데
막 지금 사진상으로는 이게 뭐
그러니까요.
다른 차별점이 어떤 건지
잘 모르긴 하겠다. 실제로 만져보면
다르겠지만
저 근데 저도 실물을 못
봤어요.
음. 근데
뭔가 코모리 옷이 가격대가 있는데 전
좀 코모리 옷을 좀 오래 입을 수
있는 옷이라고 생각하거든요.
그래가지고 뭐 데님 셋업도 있고 뭐
커트도 있고 한데 계속 어쨌든 그냥
휘뚜루마두르 입을 수 있는 옷은 결국
이쪽이더라고요. 그래가지고
뭔가
후드를 한번 사보고 싶다.음 음.
나는 사실 요즘 레미릴리프 좋아하긴
하거.
아 레미릴리프?
어
얘네도
하거.
아 레미릴리프?
어
얘네도
하거.
아 레미릴리프?
어
얘네도
워싱감이 되게 예쁘던데.음데
레밀리프
같은 워싱감 나도 빼기 어렵다고
생각하거든.
음
근데 실제로 잘 안
생각하거든.
음
근데 실제로 잘 안
생각하거든.
음
근데 실제로 잘 안
돼. 이런게 어려워.
쉽지에 있어요.
음
근데 뭐 다
쉽지에 있어요.
음
근데 뭐 다
쉽지에 있어요.
음
근데 뭐 다
예쁘고 그
선배 님이 아까 보여줬던
그런
기념품
기념품 비슷한 깔아요.
그런
기념품
기념품 비슷한 깔아요.
그런
기념품
기념품 비슷한 깔아요.
그지 그지. 맞아 맞아. 그 나는이
티셔츠 좀 사고 싶더라고 뭔가.
음.
남아 그 나름의 위트가 있네요.
그까이 프린트 기법이나 이런 것들이
사실
음
어쨌든간에 잘 못 만드는
사실
음
어쨌든간에 잘 못 만드는
사실
음
어쨌든간에 잘 못 만드는
거예 가지고 이런 거 되게 사고
싶더라고.
아 부끄럽지만 제가 이게
얼마나 어려운지 잘 몰라서
어 이거
예쁘다.
아 뭐 어렵다는 거는 사실
다 주관적인데
귀엽다.
주관적인이라기보다는 다 경험인데
왜이
비싸? 비싸네.
이거 자수야 다.
아
비싸? 비싸네.
이거 자수야 다.
아
비싸? 비싸네.
이거 자수야 다.
아
어 이거 예쁘다.
아 그래서
다 자수
어 이거 예쁘다.
아 그래서
다 자수
어 이거 예쁘다.
아 그래서
다 자수
뒤에를 못 봤네.
음
아니 이거 실제로 좀 이쁘더라고
보니까. 오.
아이 색감이 난 되게
이쁘더라고.
어 이거 예쁘다. 진짜
근데 이건 지퍼를 다 달고 나서
염색을 한 거죠.
왜냐면 여기 여기
보면은
그러네. 좀 약간 상이 있네.
그지? 그럴 그럴 가능성이 크지.
그래서 이제 지퍼 컬러 날아가는 걸
수도 있고 워싱하고
늘 몽쉘 미쉘를
돌리면
어 이뻐.이
이 브랜드 이쁘고 그다음에 내가 다른
거 본 거 있어 보는데
다 회사에서
우리 일 안 하고 우리
쇼핑하는 거
아니야?지는
시간 한 거니까
그죠?
아니야?지는
시간 한 거니까
그죠?
아니야?지는
시간 한 거니까
그죠?
브랜드가 뭐였더라? 싸주
싸주
어카더이스 레이디 와 화이트도 있죠
괜찮은데
어 레이 아 일단 레이디
화이트 내가 최근에 샀던 레이디
화이트 티셔츠가
그래 구독자분이
티셔츠 여기 거 추천했어요. 내가
럭비 티셔츠 이거 하나 샀거든.
음.
근데 이게 피쁘더라고.
아, 그래요?
근데 두꺼워 옷이
이번 시즌께 좀
두<un다고 하더라고.
옛라인부터가
근데 짱짱해 뭐 진짜 두꺼워
보이는데요.
짱짱해. 근데 두껍고 한
여름에 진짜 더울 것 같아 생각
하는데 이게 원단이 탄탄하니까 그
실로에서 잡아주는게 있더라고. 막
이렇게 흐르는게 아니고
딱 이거야.
넌 이걸 이렇게 그냥 갇혀 있어야
돼. 이런 느낌.
약간 갑옷 같은
느낌이
어. 난이 반팔 되게
이쁘더라고. 내가 최근에 사 가지고
오버예요. 아니면 어때요?
이게
적당히 세미오버야.
세미오버.
어.
적당히 세미오버야.
세미오버.
어.
적당히 세미오버야.
세미오버.
어.
되게 좋았어. 내가 아 이거였던 거
같아.
아 이쁘다.
아이 아우터가
같아.
아 이쁘다.
아이 아우터가
같아.
아 이쁘다.
아이 아우터가
되게 이쁘더라고.
얘네 퀄리티 되게
좋아요.
그지?
나이 브랜드를 사실
좋아요.
그지?
나이 브랜드를 사실
좋아요.
그지?
나이 브랜드를 사실
어 이거 입은 거 보면 되게 예쁘다.
여기서 처음 알게 되는데
어카인도가이스라 브랜드가 난 되게
옷들이 다 괜찮아 가지고
이게 베릴린
베이스인 거 같던데. 아, 그래요?
베르린이 어쨌든 독일 옷인데 전 독일
애들이 옷을 되게 은근 잘 맞는다고
생각해요.
우리나라에서는 아직 막
그렇게 가강받는 느낌은 아니지만.
음.
저는 품목인데 위시리스트
그 제가
예전에 있었던 옷 중에 이게 있어요.
라프시무스 2002 리덕스 컬렉션
중에
반팔 맨투맨인데
이걸 제가 갖고
있다가 너무
비싼 비싸다 보니까
제
있다가 너무
비싼 비싸다 보니까
제
있다가 너무
비싼 비싸다 보니까
제
팔았어요.
이런 반팔 맨투맨이 되게
예쁘더라고요. 금태균 님 유튜브에도
그 무슨 빈티지샵을 본인이 자주 가는
빈티지샵을 공유했더라고요.
음. 이런
걸 하나 사고 싶더라고요. 사실이 전
이게 너무 예쁜 거예요. 음.이
맨투맨이.
음.
근데 PC 저렇게 딱
맨투맨이.
음.
근데 PC 저렇게 딱
맨투맨이.
음.
근데 PC 저렇게 딱
떨어지는게 좋은 거야?
저는 그 반팔
맨투맨은 피타이 있는게 더 좋다고
생각해.
반팔 맨투맨이에요.
반팔 맨투맨. 맨투맨이에.
아, 그래? 어. 아, 반팔
멘토맨이구나. 셔츠가 아니구나.
네.
보시면
아, 그러네. 아, 그러네요.
얘도 얘도 맨투맨 얘도
아, 얘도
맨투맨이야.
예. 스웨셔츠
아
이쪽
맨투맨이야.
예. 스웨셔츠
아
이쪽
맨투맨이야.
예. 스웨셔츠
아
이쪽
지금 입어야 되겠다.
예
여름 되면
지금 입어야 되겠다.
예
여름 되면
지금 입어야 되겠다.
예
여름 되면
한 여름에 못 입잖아. 근데
얘는 못
입지
귀엽네. 준야는 너무 살아서 못
사겠고
준니야 이거 비쌀 거 같지.
어 근데 이제 기본 원래 항상 이제
준야 나오고 그다음에 일반 모델들
나오잖아. 그래서 일반 모델들 좀
사보고 싶다는 생각 계속 하고 있어
가지고
내 구동화를 미즈기 하나
있어. 웨이브 목이라고. 아
어 봐.
내가 가지고 있는 거는
이거 오른쪽을 가지고 있어. 음.
근데 이제 그
이거네
이거지? 어.
근데 이제 그
이거네
이거지? 어.
근데 이제 그
이거네
이거지? 어.
이런 거지.
예쁘다.
응. 이게 지금
이런 거지.
예쁘다.
응. 이게 지금
이런 거지.
예쁘다.
응. 이게 지금
보니까 리셀가가 한 20만 원
중반대밖에 없 아니더라고. 이게
발매가가 23만9,000원인가?
그래서
괜찮네요. 거의 사실상
어
그래서
괜찮네요. 거의 사실상
어
그래서
괜찮네요. 거의 사실상
어
거의 한 만 원 2만 원 돈만
킨 한
마리도 아니네.
어
그래서 이걸 지금
마리도 아니네.
어
그래서 이걸 지금
마리도 아니네.
어
그래서 이걸 지금
살까 고민하고 있었고 그다음에 이제
우리가 여름 대비해야 되잖아.
아
여름 대비.
어 여름 대비 생각했을
또 난 센달을 좀 많이 쉬는데.
아
그래요? 키의 뉴포트라는 모델이
있거든.
근데 이제이 살짝 그 거친 느낌이
있더라고. 소재가 다른 거랑 다르게
약간 거끌거해 보이긴 하는데요.
그래서 이번에 좀 사고 싶다는 생각
계속 하고 있었었는데 구매를
하잖아요. 이게 보통
얼마예요? 얘는
한 16만 원 우리나라에서 했던 거
같아.
보통 그 어퍼가 베이지면은
얘네가 보통 아래도 베이지 컬러 많이
했었거든. 근데 이제 이거는 미창이
검정색이어서 되게 여러 군데 다 입을
수 있겠다 신을 수 있겠다 싶어
가지고
그래서 이거 지금 다윗
위시리스트에 들어갔어.
플레이그라운드하는 아
플레이그라운드 어 플레이그라운드
스토어라데 있거든. 이게 내가 알고
나구야에 있는데
어
근데 이제이
나구야에 있는데
어
근데 이제이
나구야에 있는데
어
근데 이제이
얘네들이 이제 그 옛날 신발들도
취구를 많이 하면서 자기네들도 신발을
만들어
근데 이제
이게 브랜드예요
편집샵이에요 둘 다
편집한 브랜드 둘
다 있는 거야 근데 이제 자기
어조도는 뭐야
그니까 이제 옛날
신발들 갖다 와서 파는 거지
빈티지
와 너무 텐 진짜
이게 사고
빈티지
와 너무 텐 진짜
이게 사고
빈티지
와 너무 텐 진짜
이게 사고
싶더라고요
아 이건 얘네가 만든 거예요 어 얘네
만드신발이야. 그게 센달이거든.
음.
아 서면이 잘 신으실 것 같은데요.
또 비브람이네. 와 저런 비브라면
처음 본다. 그러니까
어 그러네.
뭔가
뭔가크 느낌에
이런 룩
귀엽다.
뭔가
뭔가크 느낌에
이런 룩
귀엽다.
뭔가
뭔가크 느낌에
이런 룩
귀엽다.
신으면 되게 귀엽겠더라고.
그래서이 브랜드를 난 원래 좀 계속
보곤 있었는데 우리나라 취급한 데는
거의 없어.
처음 봐요. 저는
슬로우스테디 클럽 정도 취급을 하는데
근데 그게 잘 팔리진 않나 봐.
아
이것도 이쁘
한정적이. 근데 나도
이것도 이쁘더라고. 플레이그라운드.
근데 근데 가벼우면 편할 것 같은데
그걸 잘 모르겠다.
그지?
가벼워
그걸 잘 모르겠다.
그지?
가벼워
그걸 잘 모르겠다.
그지?
가벼워
보이긴 하는데
근데 내가 느끼기에는
사실 이런 형태의 신발들이 나이키에서
옛날에 많이 나왔거든.
2000년대
초반에
그렇다고 알고 있어. 근데
그런 거에
이거 나이키 달린 나이키
이거 달리고 있었는데 예전에
그지?
근데 영감을 받아서 만든게 아닌가라는
생각이 들더라고.
약간 야구공처럼
생겼다.
어 그래서이 신발 좀 사고
싶다 생각했다.
플레이그라운드. 어
이건 진짜 좀
아까 슬리퍼는 선님
무조건 두 달 후에 신고 있을 것
같아.
그려줘요.
아 근데 사고 싶은
같아.
그려줘요.
아 근데 사고 싶은
같아.
그려줘요.
아 근데 사고 싶은
거 너무 많아. 보면 볼수록이 건물
생심이야 진짜.
맞아요. 아 저는
사실 이거 그냥 살려고 했거든요.
근데 실
이거 그냥 살려
아니
근데 실
이거 그냥 살려
아니
근데 실
이거 그냥 살려
아니
실패했어요. 또 또 이거긴 한데
디스트릭트
아 뭔지 알 것 같아.
거기서 벗어난지 못하시네.
그 발바닥
같은 거 아니야? 맞아요. 맞아요.
아 이거를 제가 알림을 신청해 놓고
이게
금요일 11시인가 목요일 11시
발매어서 땅 한 거 들어갔는데 앱이
터진 거예요.
아 진짜
네. 그리고
터진 거예요.
아 진짜
네. 그리고
터진 거예요.
아 진짜
네. 그리고
그래서 3분 뒤에 켜졌는데 다 나가
가지고
이거 근데 일반 모델도 나오지
않았어? 디젤 기전 말 고급형도
나왔을맞 얘가 아마 트레 트레일화일
거예요. 그래가지고
그렇게 생겼네요.
트레일화 화화화는 사실 발목 꺾이는게
있어 가지고 높음이 안 되거든요.
그래가지고 낮게 나온 걸로 알고
있어서 그냥 트레일화 겸 뭐 일상화로
하나 사 볼까 했는데 터져 가지고
그래서 아 그냥 터지고 나서 아 내게
아닌가 보다 포기하고 있는데
음이
색깔로요?
어 얘는 뭔 색깔이야?
얘는 브라운이야.
나이 둘 다
솔더 아 보여주지.
신발이 너무 많아 가지고.
아 그지?
근데 신발은 뭔가 계속 사게 돼.
그러니까요.
제 신발장 못 보셨잖아.
어 터져.
지금 이따 나가면
아니 신발을 계속 하면 엄마가 뭐라
해.
아 진짜 이거 할 말이 많은데
진짜
신발은 제가 제방에서가 놀 순
없잖아요.냄.
계속이 여기다 신발장에
놓다 보니까 공룡이고
너무 플랫한 거
좋아하. 블랙탄 거 좋아하는데 제가
최근에 다시 좀 보게 된 브랜드가
아오레가시거든요.
아오레가씨
제가
아오레가시거든요.
아오레가씨
제가
아오레가시거든요.
아오레가씨
제가
갖고 있는 옷이 한 16 17 시즌
이때 좀 좋아하고 많이 샀었는데음
요즘 다시 좀 다시 보게 되더라고요.
그래서
최근에
에딕티드를 갔었는데 좀
가죽이
샀잖아.
예. 가죽바지 샀죠.
가죽어.
예. 아울렛 같이 가족을 그
아울렛 세이 때 샀는데
그러고 나서
내려오면서 봤는데
최근 시즌 중에
괜찮은 신발이 하나 있는 거예요.
어디어?
아 품절인데.
아니 나 왠지
어디어?
아 품절인데.
아니 나 왠지
어디어?
아 품절인데.
아니 나 왠지
너 이거 얘기할 거라 생각했는데
이거요?
어
이신발이요? 어
나도
이거요?
어
이신발이요? 어
나도
이거요?
어
이신발이요? 어
나도
이거 이쁘다 생각했거든.이
신발
어음
이게 왜냐면 납자기 중에 척당이
이렇게 라운드가 들어간
좀 아 옛날
스탠스미스 쉐입이라고 해야 될까요?
아니 앞에 쉐입이 되게 이뻐 이게.
살짝 그 사각형 같기도 하고
맞아요.
근데 옆에서 봤을 때 너 갖고 있는
그 프라다랑 비슷해. 느낌이
아니에요. 옆에서 봤어. 옆에서.
아
근데 이거 이뻤어. 나도 이쁘다
생각했어.이 왜냐면이 옆이 옆태가 딱
옆에서 봤을 때 엄청 네모네요. 음.
아 근데 아오래가 신발은 그 까미온
뮤잖아. 그거는 되게 잘 신었어.
음.
아 그까 그 시 그 시계 그
내가 엄청 무겁지 않아요?
엄청
무거워. 근데 그거 신으면은 무릎
나갈 것 같은데 진짜
발목이랑. 그다음에 아오레가 씨 중에
내가 좋아했던 건 나오토. 나우토 좀
사고 싶어요.
나우토 스펠링이
뭐예요?
그 그냥 Nao
어
음
이거거든.
어
음
이거거든.
어
음
이거거든.
오
알기로는 국내에서선 별로 인기
없다고 들었거든. 근데 저 미창이
되게 이쁘더라고 나는.
그 위에 이제
저렇게
약간 느낌 미창이 예쁘다.
미창이 이쁘지.
근데 인기
없대. 별로 인기 없대.
아 옛날에 나왔나 보다.
근데 이거
아마 할인해서 다 팔렸을 거야.
솔다
근데 요게이 부분이 독특하다.
어
그래서 그 부분이 되게 나는 이쁘다
생각했었거든. 아오리가씨
신발들이 나올 때 이쁜 것들이 꽤
있어.
음. 어 이쁘다.
밥 먹으러 갈까요?
네. Ah.